uh this is like a random tangent
like since we're on like the topic of
sense and onsens and stuff like that how
do you guys feel how do you guys feel
about massages
because
i don't i don't know if it's because i'm
thai and when i think massage i think
thai massage i can't [ __ ] stand
massages really yeah you don't like it i
i like
sometimes i'm just like sometimes you
get a massage and i'm just like why did
i pay someone like [ __ ] why did i pay
someone just to beat the [ __ ] out of me
for an hour like
i feel like i'm not old enough to enjoy
them yet yeah i feel like i haven't i
feel in 10 years time oh really
i feel like i'm still at that age where
i'm just worrying about every single
aspect of the massage when i'm there i'm
like what if they tickle my feet you
know what if
what if i'm
what if they what if they uh they think
my body's ugly you know all these things
are very uh you know because i had one
where i had to like you know we have to
take off your shirt and stuff i'm like
oh god yes but i but you have to right
yeah sometimes you have to be nude right
yes i'm some massage place i'm just not
at that age where i can appreciate it
yeah also to me it's like i don't know
my body isn't like sore enough
that someone massaging me feels good it
feels good but it doesn't feel like
worth the like hundred bucks you can be
right exactly like i mean i
like i i hear stories because like and
this has happened to me as well where
you go for massage and like it's so
[ __ ] hard that you just like tears
start coming out and people wear like a
badge of honor like oh man i i went to
the middle
so much i started crying and i'm just
like you you paid for this why why why
would you pay someone to like tear your
ligament like that that just doesn't
make sense to me but again like i feel
you know when i get to like my 30s and
40s when you know naturally your body is
gonna start to deteriorate it's gonna
start to get sore that's i feel the
point where i'll be like [ __ ] i go for a
massage yeah but as of right now it's
like if my body saw i'll just do a
couple things i just feel like
you know when i go to these massage
things i'm like
even though i'm sure they're trained i'm
like i feel like you just
you're just beating the [ __ ] out of me
you're just beating the [ __ ] out of me i
feel like you're not really doing
anything i feel like i feel like you
know i want to question the the training
authority
uh approval today yeah yeah yeah like
like honestly like especially like i
don't know how people can go to massages
for like two three hours
like it's i feel like you need to know
someone who knows the best part because
i've had it in hotels before oh hotels
massages i just thought like this is
just weird i just didn't like this i
felt like i felt like someone called you
up you reluctantly showed up and now
you're just beating the [ __ ] out of me i
feel like you had no appointments
scheduled today
i'm the [ __ ] who scheduled one
appointment today and you came in on
your day off and now you're beating the
[ __ ] out of me
and you i'm not saying you have to enjoy
it i don't want you to enjoy it but i
also i don't want you to [ __ ] hate me
for getting a massage you know i paid
money i don't want to i don't want to
feel like i'm i'm being his stan what do
you guys feel about saunas i [ __ ]
love saunas bro really i i am a weak
little baby when it comes to saunas my
god like every time every time we go to
an onsen and we sit there like a minute
passes i'm like i'm done you because
you're doing everyone does sauna's wrong
no one goes in the water before they go
in the sauna do you mean you have to go
in the cold water before you go in i
just think i'm very sensitive or not
sensitive i'm like my
no one enjoys going in the cold water
it's [ __ ] awful
no i'm not talking about cold water i'm
talking about heat
right yeah if you go in there
after just going in the onsen when your
body's already at like 37 38 degrees
fully heated up yeah it's going to be
hell go in the cold water then go in and
you'll be able to do it perfectly no
because i i just feel i just feel like
you know whenever we go to the onsen i'm
always the one who goes into the even
the water the least just because like i
can't sit or i can't like my tolerance
to
being in hot places or like sitting in a
hot place for like a long time is just
[ __ ] [ __ ] did you go in the cold
water
what is that you go in the cold water
this is important
okay did you go in the cold water no i
didn't there you go you're honest wait
wait you go in the cold water before you
jump in the onset uh before the sauna
sauna i'm supposed to go in after this
one after and then go back in ah
but like
well like but like sometimes sometimes
you go to nonsense it's just like way
too hot i don't know like that's why i
jump in the cold water
so to me to me that it's to me it's
meant to be a relaxing experience and i
shouldn't need to like
like do a compromise to have a relaxing
experience you know yeah i don't want to
like you know give myself pain on the
opposite end i want a victim too i want
to be comfortable yeah you know i'm not
paying to give myself an ice bucket
challenge you know you [ __ ] do that
for charity man
yeah sorry i was googling so i was like
making i was like i swear there's like
health benefits to uh going in the
uh the cold sauna after especially when
you heat your body up it's like really
there's amazing health benefits no no i
i know like saunas
health benefits so it's like when you
get out of that cold water after going
in the sauna as well god damn does your
body feel good oh yeah i'm sure that's
like you know that's like
saying that there's a health benefit
which i'm sure there is to taking a cold
shower in the morning but i'm pretty
sure but i don't want to call it shut up
but i'm pretty sure it's only
psychological
in the [ __ ] navy seals next time
uh to the onsen please go jump in the
cold water after i swear to god you'll
feel amazing after the sauna after and
before okay i i'll go in i've gone in
after the sauna yeah because that's what
you're supposed to do and it feels
[ __ ] great going before as well
before
dude because then you go in the sauna
and it's heating your body up it feels
very nice i just don't like much i just
don't enjoy saunas because it's because
in japan they suck right in every time i
went in europe it was like you're in the
sauna tm with the boys you know you you
you chat and you laugh and you have a
good time in the sauna you talk in japan
it's like
it's like a lot of talk in the sauna
yeah it's like an interrogation room no
one talks it's just like everyone's just
sitting there and it's like really
awkward and i feel like sauna is where
the camaraderie should come out with you
and the boys maybe she's been skiing
she's been out in the snow whatever i
don't know what the [ __ ] you've been
doing but you talk in the sauna you
laugh yeah that's me that's awesome the
onsen though that's that's that's where
the onsen you can do that in the onsen
with less pain yeah yeah but that's how
you get through the sauna as well by
talking with the boys
yeah because if you think about being in
the sauna you can't say in a song if
you've never been in the sauna uh i i
mean you can't really relate to this but
yeah it's a very hot ring what a [ __ ]
sauna it's just a hot room hot room a
really hot room what do you think of
like saunas versus steam rooms
i prefer sauna
what's the difference oh this one is
like dry oh right right it's like it's
like 90 degrees yeah the steam room is
just like japanese summer simulator oh
[ __ ] that no it's not all the way
more common but uh steam rooms are
similar but i thought the steam room
sounds horrible that's not that bad
actually but i hate the humidity
well i just look at you sweating yeah
right and i i i like nice though i
prefer steam rooms because it feels like
it it takes longer before
i sweat in the sauna it feels good to
sweat basically that's that's why you're
sitting in the sauna right steamroom
just like it it makes that process a bit
faster so i have to stay in there for
shorter a shorter amount of time i just
i just feel like i i get like a re a
relaxing senshi relaxing sensation that
i just can't get anywhere else other
than the sauna cold water combo nothing
like it relaxes me have you tried taking
a 40 minute [ __ ] that's uh
you guys are like a xanax or something
i was like
melatonin
it's so nice if you're scared of it just
just do one leg in at a time just slowly
get in there and
yeah you just i can't i feel like i feel
like you can't do the one leg at a time
you've got to jump in be careful though
you can go into shock from doing it yeah
right yeah that's what i'm scared of you
just have to that's why you shouldn't
sometimes you shouldn't jump in it
depends on what you are and how easy you
get lightheaded yeah uh i think i nearly
went into shock one time when i did it
jeez i jumped in and my heart was like
and i was like i just like calm down but
oh [ __ ] i spat
like like calm my body down because i
felt like i was gonna go into shock oh
it's terrible because your chest goes
super tight if you do too fast yeah yeah
i mean you're basically experiencing
hypothermia well you're going you're
going from 90 degree room to 20 degree
water yeah that like submerges your body
instantly so you need to be careful but
it is really fun uh just be careful
but uh yeah it's bad some of the best
things in life are you know very
worrying yeah